in just a matter of seconds a crime so
Brazen can cut off a life Supply up and
down the UK criminals are stealing
catalytic converters wherever they can
find them at whatever time of day it
still leaves me in shock just seeing
that when even though I've seen it time
and again and
I just can't believe that somebody will
be so rude so blatant
it's bad enough having it happen to you
once but Margaret has had a catalytic
converter stolen three times in just two
years leaving her car unusable
it sounds really extreme to say I was on
the edge the last time it happened but I
really was because
um
like I say we don't earn a lot of money
we don't have a great deal of things for
somebody just to come along and in three
minutes it changes your life really it
it impacts so hard
um
mentally it's
very hard to take very
with a disabled husband and a 50-mile
round trip to work the knock-on effect
of what seems like a minor crime has
been devastating I feel so awful for my
husband more so than myself really
because
it's his Lifeline you know I I've got
the ability to get buses and trains and
things but for him he can't get out
during the day it's very disabling and
for something that was the to help his
Mobility that person is now again
disabled the emotional strain is clear
and will be felt by many who are victims
to this crime which we can reveal has
shot up in recent years data obtained by
Sky News from every police force in the
UK shows in the last three years there
have been almost a hundred thousand
recorded thefts of catalytic converters
in the 12 months from the 1st of
December 2021 almost 28 000 devices were
stolen though down from last year it's a
25 increase from 2019.
on average 75 catalytic converters were
stolen per day this year
now these figures alone may be alarming
but you have to take into account this
is a crime hugely underreported in
reality there are many more catalytic
converters stolen than on record meaning
many more lives deeply impacted but the
theft is just one element of a chain of
crimes involving these devices which are
so sought after
inside all those layers there are this
set of platinum Metals uh rhodium
Palladium and platinum and they are
extremely valuable so they can be up to
four thousand pounds of troy ounce which
is equivalent to about 31 grams of this
powdered metal and that could equate to
about six seven catalytic converters
because of the value they become a very
attractive
um uh Target for for criminals and it's
gradually I think it's attracted
organized crime as well
it's why police forces using covert
operations are trying to clamp down on
the buying selling and stealing of this
car part with some progress already made
just last year in the first two weeks of
our operation will reduce crime by 50
nationally but again 30 000 offenses
over the last 12 months and we need that
information about who's involved so
either the public they may have an idea
Who's involved or the waste industry and
that information is absolutely critical
to help us get out lock up people and
even last year we just one operation we
recovered over 2 000 stolen Catholic
converters so we're doing the work we
just need that critical intelligence and
information for people that will help us
do our job even better
but despite their efforts majority of
catalytic converter thefts go unsolved
and whilst it may be a lucrative crime
for those involved
for a single mum of three whose car was
targeted the financial repercussions are
crippling they may as well have come in
you know runs at the house because that
car was my lifeline it was a BMW Series
one it was 14 years old it was worth
twelve hundred pounds you know I don't
have much I'm on my own with three
children putting myself through
University to better our lives and then
you're given a bill of nearly a thousand
pound every way I kind of looked for a
solution I was faced with
more of a challenge financially with a
higher insurance premium and the chance
of Thieves targeting her car again
Claire scrapped the BMW and was forced
to take a 4 000 pound loan to buy a new
car they couldn't have done anything any
worse you know it wasn't just the car
breaking down what they did in that five
minutes I'm probably not gonna get back
um level with finances till beginning of
Summer next year it completely destroyed
and has left me in such a mess
as the crime has risen so too has the
price to replace these devices
something the AAA has noticed has
callouts for this problem are
increasingly common it has a massive
impact on people because these catalytic
converters they aren't cheap to buy from
the the you know from the manufacturers
so some some customers can Fork out as
much as fifteen hundred pounds just to
get the car back on the road I've seen
some dealerships that are taking quite a
while to get them in stock certainly
from over in Asia and stuff like that
getting them across to the UK has been
quite difficult
on the face of it it may look like just
a smaller fence but these are thefts
being carried out on a large scale
that's every juncture of this crime it's
clear the criminals aren't letting up
leaving victims helpless vulnerable and
with consequences often irreversible
into man Rashid Sky News